today on the mat wall show professional
victim Colin Kaepernick has a new book
to promote which means it's time to
complain about oppression again except
this time it's not just his country he
throws under the bus it's his parents
too also Glenn Younkin is confronted by
a quote-unquote trans man during a CNN
Town Hall Ayanna Presley struggles to
explain why abortion is a valid medical
treatment the journalists who publish
the Twitter files testify in front of
Congress and in our daily cancellation I
am forced to cancel a whole swarm of
tick-tockers all at once all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
ha
I believe in working hard for what you
have you uh who do you trust to handle
any and all of your financial
obligations if you can according to a
recent poll 62 of Americans who think
about their own death a lot of the time
still do not have a will that's kind of
like being afraid of drowning but
refusing to wear a life jacket creating
a will is one of the most important
things you can do to ensure that your
belongings and your loved ones are taken
care of after you pass away my partners
at Epic will can help you get set up
with a will today for just 119 in as
little as five minutes epic will can
help you create your last will and
testament your living will even Health
Care power of attorney go to
epicwill.com Walsh to get my discount
code an extra an extra 10 off on your
complete will package with epic wheels
easy to use template all you have to do
is fill in the blanks they couldn't make
it easier for you go to epicworld.com
Walsh to save 10 on Epic Will's complete
will package that's epicwill.com Walsh
today
I would say that Colin Kaepernick is the
Meghan Markle of the sports world but
that wouldn't be quite accurate sure
like Markle he's a wealthy privileged
brat just as white as he is black but
nonetheless obsessed with his entirely
imagined racial victimhood
um so that's similar but there are some
crucial caveats first uh for one thing
Kaepernick can't really be the Markle of
the sports world because he isn't an
athlete unless you account the
oppression Olympics as an actual sport
which Perhaps it is or one day will be
and for another to his credit he didn't
have to marry into his victimhood unlike
Markle Colin Kaepernick isn't writing
anyone's coattails he achieved his
status as faux martyr and insufferable
obnoxious prick all on his own
actually the more I think about it he we
we might say that Kaepernick is sort of
Megan and Harry combined if you mix the
two Royal whiners together and you
combine their powers you end up with
Kaepernick he's like he's like the
self-victimizing Megazord he has
markle's fake racial grievances but he
also has Harry's disloyalty and his
pension for um throwing his own family
onto the bus and driving over them and
then backing up and driving over them
again and then again and again and again
he is such a perfect amalgamation of the
two such a manifestation of the worst
aspects of both of them they almost
wonder whether by some strange Time Warp
he might actually be their child is
Kaepernick the adult son of Harry and
Megan who has come back in time to
experience and exploit this era of woke
victimhood that's a possibility we need
to discuss there's there's a conspiracy
theory I can get on board with maybe or
at least it's just a screenplay someone
should write at the very least
but assuming that Kaepernick is not a
victimhood chasing time traveler then
the real story is that he was conceived
by a white woman and a black man and he
was then abandoned by his black father
put up for adoption as an infant and
taken in by a white couple his white
adoptive parents raised him gave him a
blessed and comfortable life supported
him loved him and now after all of that
they find themselves somehow the objects
of their adopted son's animosity
that is whenever he has something to
promote at least
and this week he's promoting a new book
which means they're going right into the
bus yet again here's the New York Post
report says controversial football star
Colin Kaepernick accused his white
adoptive parents of perpetuating racism
in a new interview the former NFL star
told CBS Chicago that he struggled
growing up in a problematic household a
through line he details in his upcoming
graphic novel changed the game graphic
novel tells the story of Kaepernick's
Journey from high school into his
storied athletic career that well
storied athletic careers oh look it's uh
maybe a little bit overstating it that
heavily centers around his lack of
choice in his future his parents
particularly tried to steer him in a
Direction they thought was best which
led to several fights between them and
their adopted son
can you imagine that parents tried to
steer their child in the direction they
think is best what parent would ever do
that
here's a clip of the interview check it
out
who's spreading a message of empowerment
in his new graphic novel changed the
game written with author and University
of Chicago Professor Eve l u e I love
how you depict yourself in this book not
as some big shot hero but as a shy
insecure high schooler like we all were
I mean I'm speaking for you but yeah no
absolutely absolutely growing up I was a
I think still I'm a pretty introverted
person I hope it's true to form and
that's just kind of how I navigate the
world it's his true High School Coming
of Age story his journey embracing his
Blackness despite resistance from many
including his white adoptive parents I
know my parents love me but they were
still very problematic things that
I went through I think it was important
to show that no this can happen in your
own home and how we move forward
collectively while addressing the racism
that is being perpetuated he took cues
from his icon basketball star Alan
Iverson who he said wore his Blackness
like a suit of armor and teenage
Kaepernick wanted cornrows to match he's
getting what roles his mom asked oh your
hair is not professional oh you look
like a little Thug
yeah and those become spaces where it's
like okay how do I navigate this
situation now but it also is informed
why I have my hair long today the
grown-up version of Eve wanted to go
back in time and give young Colin a lot
of hugs and I was really moved and
saddened by the level of kind of
self-awareness that he had to develop at
a very young age without a lot of
guidance
now uh I certainly am not making any
excuses for this guy he's a scumbag of
the lowest kind there's no getting
around that
you can also tell that the man has been
severely brainwashed as time goes on
with each successive interview he sounds
more and more like like a 55 year old
white woman holding a corporate
diversity seminar we just listen to the
words and the phrases that he uses
problematic
perpetuating racism move forward
collectively and then my favorite
navigate these spaces how do we navigate
these spaces
no human being naturally speaks that way
okay a former athlete especially does
not speak that way you're not gonna hear
a football player in the locker room
saying to his teammates listen fellas
there's a lot of problematic Behavior
going on in here we really need to
figure out how to navigate these spaces
so we can move forward collectively
respecting each other's lived
experiences so that we can unpack our
oppression and curate an understanding
of our intersectional realities and
together come up with solution-oriented
perspectives liberated from our
post-colonial trauma
it's just not how human beings speak
okay rather it's how a Dei diversity you
know uh robot is programmed
and that's what Colin Kaepernick has
become basically
so what is his complaint against his
parents yes they took him in yes they
raised and loved him yes they they gave
him a wonderful and privileged life yes
they supported him and they set him up
for Success yes they did everything for
him
but they criticized his hairstyle so all
of that is irrelevant
I mean that is that is a resentment he
holds with him today he he still
determines how he Styles his hair today
based on what his parents told him not
to do when he was a teenager
now he has a point though I will admit I
mean it really is unprecedented for
parents to complain about their
children's hairstyles
right it's not like literally every
parent on Earth has this kind of
conversation with their teenage children
it's not like every parent I mean
literally every parent white or black or
whatever color has to at some point give
their child a lecture about the
importance of maintaining a professional
haircut and and appearance
actually come to think of it um
it's not entirely impressive so I guess
Colin Kaepernick went through this and
then and then the only other person in
in the history of the world was me
because I could remember can remember
when I first started developing facial
hair so I would have been about three or
four at the time and I wanted to grow a
goatee but my dad he he took one look at
what I was trying to do there and he
told me that it looks ridiculous and
unacceptable his words exactly and
forced me to shave so
when is CBS gonna interview me so I can
tell my story where's my book deal to
unpack my trauma
but then again I wouldn't take that book
deal even if it was offered because I'd
rather be broke and homeless than earn
money by publicly stabbing my own family
in the back
of all the ways to earn money that is
among the most disgraceful it's worse
than prostitution perhaps perhaps it's a
type of prostitution actually Colin
Kaepernick is a in his own way
prostituting himself by selling his
Integrity selling out his own family in
exchange for victim points
now it's well established of course that
um that Kaepernick's victimhood
narrative is totally fanciful he grew up
comfortable he became a professional
athlete he decided to transition to
social justice Warrior after his playing
career had taken a nosedive based on his
poor performance after he got benched uh
for uh you know for Blaine Gabbert which
is pretty much the the the worst
humiliation a football player can
possibly experience
and then that happens and he becomes a
social justice Warrior and through his
social justice charade finds wealth and
fame far beyond anything the NFL could
ever provide for him
he has not been
disadvantaged by his quote unquote
blackness
but rather he has profited immensely
from it here's an indisputable fact okay
this could not be disputed if everything
about Kaepernick was the same
except that he was fully white rather
than just half white okay if his
deadbeat biological father was white
instead of black let's say then
Kaepernick would today at the age of 35
or 36 however old he is he would today
be an obscure washed out backup
quarterback with um with a with a a net
worth and profile barely a fraction of
what it currently is
you wouldn't have any endorsements you
wouldn't have any book deals he wouldn't
have any Netflix series
at the very best he'd appear on ESPN
occasionally to debate the other Talking
Heads about whether uh Joe burrow has a
higher ceiling than Patrick Mahomes or
whatever
more likely he'd have drifted off into
complete obscurity by now and maybe he'd
own a strip mall or a car dealership or
something
his Blackness has opened up very
lucrative doors that wouldn't exist
without it
that's indisputable the the fully white
version of Colin Kaepernick is in a much
worse spot today
than the half white version
so we don't need to analyze his
victimhood claims they're utterly bogus
they're laughable on their face
instead what we should focus on when it
comes to Kaepernick
is his absolute lack of gratitude
and in this way he is a microcosm or One
symptom of a culture-wide epidemic and
that epidemic is ingratitude
you cannot have a functioning Society
without a rich atmosphere of gratitude
gratitude felt and demonstrated by the
younger Generations towards those who
came before and gave them everything
that they have and this gratitude should
be especially extended to uh to and
begin with your family and your direct
benefactors
but it should go beyond that to your
nation and your nation's forebears
now this doesn't mean that you have to
pretend that your family was perfect or
your country is perfect
gratitude doesn't require Perfection it
shouldn't require it
what it means is that you recognize what
was built for you what was provided to
you what sacrifices were made for you
and for your sake that that and that
this recognition breeds respect and
loyalty and humility
and a palpable sense of thankfulness
where would Kaepernick be if not for his
adoptive parents
where would it be if he'd been born in
another country
I mean you take either his adoptive
parents or his country out of the
equation
is there any chance you'd have a better
life right now
that's inconceivable
there's a very good chance he'd be
living in the gutter or dead in it
without the very people and the Very
Nation you can't stop complaining about
does he ever acknowledge that ever does
he ever say it out loud do any of these
self-victimizing drama queens ever
acknowledge that
of course they don't gratitude destroys
the grift
and it's much more profitable to be a
rotten disloyal little punk
than it is to be grateful and humble
much more profitable to be a spoiled
child who's never satisfied no matter
how much he is given
no matter what anyone does for him
and that is Kaepernick in a nutshell
but he is right about one thing this
country does have some serious problems
big problems
and one of the biggest one of the
biggest problems
is that it produces people like him
now let's get to our five headlines
if you had two cups of coffee that came
from the same pot but one of them cost
two dollars and the other costs one
dollar which cup would you buy sounds
like a math problem but it's actually
not that difficult of course you'd buy
the more affordable one it's the same
coffee for Less what if I told you that
you could get the same wireless service
for Less Pure Talk saves the average
family over 900 a year when they switch
from Verizon at T or T-Mobile if the
average family of three to four uh saves
over 900 a year think about how much a
family of eight could save while still
enjoying Ultra fast 5G service Pure Talk
is so sure you're gonna love your
service they're uh backing it up with a
100 money back guarantee so stop paying
a fortune to Verizon at T or T-Mobile
cut your bill in half with pure talk
they're us-based customer service team
makes the switch really easy switch over
to Pure Talk in as little as 10 minutes
uh while keeping your phone and your
phone number your first month is
guaranteed risk free speaking of
families of eight that's my family and
we use pure talk and the one thing I
love about it is not only is it more
affordable but also it's just uh it's a
it's a great service you have all the
same coverage I don't have any problems
with the phone dropping out there is no
downside to this go to puretalk.com
enter promo code Walsh to save 50 off
your first month that's puretalk.com
promo code walls Pure Talk is simply
smarter Wireless restrictions apply
Seaside for details
all right Glenn yunkin uh did a CNN Town
Hall last night where he was pressed on
education issues and various things came
up CRT came up uh then of course the
gender issue also came up on a play
um one piece of uh of that exchange for
you here it is
Governor youngin your transgender model
policies required that students play on
the sports teams and use the restrooms
that correspond with their sex assigned
at Birth look at me
I am a transgender man do you really
think that the girls in my high school
would feel comfortable sharing a
restroom with me
yep so first of all Nico thank you for
again asking the question being here
tonight and engaging in this important
discussion
I believe First when parents are engaged
with their children then you can make
good decisions together and I Met Your
Dad and I'm glad that you're both here
together that's really really important
I also think that there are lots of
students involved in this decision and
what's what's most important is that we
try very hard to accommodate students
that's why I have said many many times
we just need extra bathrooms in schools
we need General neutral bathrooms and so
people can use a bathroom that they in
fact are comfortable with
I think sports are very clear and I
don't think it's controversial I don't
think that biological boys should be
playing sports with biological girls uh
there's been Decades of efforts in order
to gain opportunities for women in
sports and it's just not fair
um and I think that's pretty that's
that's non-controversial and something
that I think is is pretty well
understood
um again I think these are very
difficult discussions and I am very very
glad to see you and your dad here
together
uh
okay so I didn't like this answer from
Young Ken at all really and I understand
he's a politician and so there are some
realities to that
um and so you can't it's not always
smart to answer questions exactly how I
would answer them if I was in that
position
but even
with that consideration still not a good
good answer first of all
we really got to stop calling this a
difficult conversation it's actually not
okay it is not a difficult conversation
um
you when you call it difficult you are
conceding already ground to the other
side because you're acting like there
are there are complexities right and
nuances that make the answers hard to
determine
when it comes to these kinds of
questions
but there aren't
girls are girls boys or boys the girl
that was talking to Glenn youngin is a
girl and so we have a girls room for you
and there's a boys room for the boys
not not a hard thing to figure out
are you a girl were you were you are you
a female
are you a girl yes well then here's the
room for you
it's not hard it's actually very very
easy
and so when we say well it's very
difficult we're you know this is really
something that we have to talk about and
we have to debate and the moment you say
that even if you land on the right
answer the moment that you've pretended
that it's actually a difficult
conversation you've you've surrendered
you've given them more ground than you
ever should have
and not not to keep beating this dead
horse but this is yet again why being
direct to the point sometimes of even
harshness
is a better approach
than trying to be so gentle by
pretending that this is so really
difficult we need to talk about it we
need to accommodate because once you
start saying that that once you have it
conceded
that this is that there's anything
complicated about this
then you've either lost the conversation
or you are on your way to losing it
it's not complicated
she's a girl she belongs in a girl's
room
um but okay for her in her particular
case
going into the girl's room is
uncomfortable and maybe it makes the
other girls uncomfortable because she is
she is presenting herself as a male
she still doesn't she doesn't look like
a male she doesn't but
um she doesn't look exactly like a
female either
um and so that that creates discomfort
and it creates discomfort in the girls
room and it creates discomfort for the
other girls perhaps
the actual and this is something we hear
this is this is a you know this is the
response from trans activists and trans
people very often when this conversation
about the bathrooms comes up
and you you get this answer all the time
and this is supposed to be a sort of a a
you know a bulletproof argument or a
trans person will come along and say
well well look at me I I look like the
opposite sex are you saying that I
should go in this bathroom
well the actual answer to that and this
is the part that I I could understand as
a politician you don't want to put it
exactly like this
but you need to find a way to say it
Because the actual answer is that
you have chosen to present yourself this
way okay you have chosen to present
yourself this way
and so
this is a this is a problem that has
been
that you have created for yourself
now in the case of a child
I'm not going to put the onus on the
child so it's a problem created by the
people that brainwashed her
because as I am always insisting
children cannot actually consent to this
but it is a problem if it's an adult
then it's a problem you've created for
yourself because if it's a child it's
tragically a problem that's been created
by the people that have brainwashed you
into this
but one way or another
you know it's um
it is a problem on the on the on the
gender ideology end of it
so maybe that's the way we put it it's a
problem that gender ideology has created
okay it's not a problem that's created
by the basic uh and sensible segregation
of male and female bathrooms
that's not the source of the problem you
see
the fact that you are presenting
yourself this way which makes it
uncomfortable in the bathroom that you
belong in
that's not a problem created by the sex
segregation of bathrooms it's a problem
created by gender ideology and by the
way that you are presenting yourself
whether you have chosen it or been
brainwashed into it that's the source of
the problem
and so what is the solution to that
problem
well the solution is reality the
solution is to stop presenting yourself
that way the solution is
for a child to counsel them and help
them to embrace reality
so that they're more comfortable in the
bathroom where they belong in and other
people are comfortable with them being
in there that's the solution the
solution is not
go go into the opposite sex bathroom the
solution is not let's create a a third
bathroom just for you to accommodate
this
no we don't want to accommodate delusion
we don't accommodate confusion we don't
accommodate brainwashing what we want to
do is counteract all of that
that's the solution
and uh Republican politicians
need to find a way to to say that
without surrendering all kinds of ground
that we cannot afford to surrender
article from the post-millennial says
Twitter files journalist Matt taibi and
Michael schellenberger appeared before
the newly formed weaponization of
government committee on Thursday and
during Congressional questioning
Democrats on the committee demanded that
taibi reveal his sources for the Twitter
files he refused during question
questioning delegate to the U.S house
from the Virgin Islands and ranking
Committee Member Stacy Plaskett
questioned taibi about who gave him
access to documents they would later use
as the basis for his reporting on the
inner workings of Twitter which became
Twitter files tahibi uh had said that a
source contacted him and asked him to be
interested in seeing those documents and
then she wanted to know who the source
was uh let's watch that Exchange
how many emails did Mr musk give you
access to
I mean we
we went through thousands of emails did
he give you access to all of the emails
for the time period in which yeah we
never had a single I never had a single
request denied and not only that but the
amount of files that we were given were
so voluminous that there was no way that
anybody could have gone through them
beforehand and we never found an
instance where anything there was any
evidence that anything had been taken
out okay so you would you would believe
that you have probably Millions
of emails and documents right that's
correct I don't know no I think the
numbers less too high okay a hundred
thousand that's probably probably
probably close to 100 000 that both of
you are saying yet in your the Twitter
files Mr taibi you've produced only 338
of those 100
000 emails is that correct that's
correct yes and then who gave you access
to these emails
who was the individual that uh gave you
permission to access the emails well the
attribution for my story is sources of
Twitter and that's what I'm going to
refer to okay
okay must contact you Mr taibi in the
attribution for my story is sources at
Twitter Mr schellenberger did Mr must
contact you uh actually no I was brought
in by my friend Barry Weiss and so this
story there's been a lot of
misinformation
Ms Weiss thank you Mr taibi have you had
conversations with Elon Musk I have okay
uh Mr Tybee did Mr musk place any
conditions on the YouTube Lady yield for
a second uh as long as my time is not
used are you trying to get journalists
no I'm not trying I'm not I am asking no
well if he will let me finish uh you and
you had conversations with him not you
said you weren't going to agree to who
your sources were I'm not asking you
your Source I'm asking you if you had
conversations with the owner of Twitter
and did Mr musk place any conditions on
your use of the emails or documents
no the in fact I was told uh explicitly
that
um we were given license to look at
present-day Twitter as well as past
Twitter
oh okay uh Mr tribe who was your source
of these documents are you asking him to
reveal sources no I'm not saying that
that's exactly what she was doing and it
is uh it is outrageous
and uh and
and actually quite chilling
to watch that exchange when you
understand what she's trying to do she
wants to know she wants to know the
sources she wants she's trying to get at
a congressional hearing she's pressuring
a journalist
to uh to reveal his sources and other
points in the questioning Democrats were
uh there was one of the Democrats there
in the committee referred to him as a
so-called journalist the questioning
whether he's really a journalist at all
and which which of course he is like
he's he is uh and he's also Matt taibi
he used to work for Rolling Stone
he is not a conservative by any stretch
of the imagination
he's actually he's a liberal journalist
and I think that he would uh not take
any issue with that
with that with that categorization
at the very least he's not he's not a
right-wing journalist at all
and if you could I remember when he when
he used to ride for Rolling Stone if you
could go back you know seven or eight
years
and like tell someone that Matt taibi of
the Rolling of Rolling Stone magazine is
going in the future will be accused of
being a right-wing propagandist
they would laugh at you because it is it
is absolutely absurd
um but here's here's where the confusion
lies that he is uh
he's definitely not right-wing
he would seem to me to be much more on
the left
but he is an actual journalist
and because he's an actual journalist
that's why the left accuses him of being
right wing
because an actual journalist is supposed
to be skeptical is supposed to act ask
questions
you're supposed to want to chase stories
and reveal things especially about
powerful institutions Twitter is one of
them
a real journalist if some if a source at
one of these major big tech companies
says hey we have evidence uh things that
were going on behind the scenes and bias
and political partisanship and all these
you know unfair you know the the terms
of service not being
not being a force failed
um things being done to influence
elections and we have we have evidence
of this we want to give you access to
any real journalist would say yeah of
course I want to see that this is this
is I exist for this that my profession
exists for moments like this
and that's what confuses them
because on the left although there are a
lot of liberal quote unquote journalists
um they don't engage in actual
journalism so when they see it happen
they assume this must be a pride this is
sub this is a secret agent for
conservatives
and the other thing about that we know
about Democrats is that they really they
get very they become very afraid
when information is revealed they don't
like information coming out to the
public
that's why we've got just in the last
week two examples of this
trying to shut down Tucker Carlson from
releasing
unseen footage from January 6 more
information they don't want that and
they also don't want more information
about what happened behind the scenes at
Twitter to be released
staying in Congress unfortunately Ayanna
Presley on the floor of Congress once
again passionately defending the murder
of children let's um haven't heard
anyone make a good argument for this yet
but let's see how she does
I rise today on behalf of the people
across our nation seeking access to
abortion care while there are many
forces and people at work who seek to
spread lies and misinformation let me
set the record straight abortion care is
routine Medical Care abortion care is
safe abortion care is a fundamental
human right abortion care is health care
and one in Four Women in this country
seek it women that
you know love work and worship with
right now a pending court case in Texas
aims to restrict access to medication
abortion across the entire nation over
40 percent of abortion care in this
nation is a medication abortion a simple
and safe protocol where patients are
prescribed two medications to end a
pregnancy a single man a far-right trump
appointed judge in Texas stands to make
a decision that could strike down the
fda's approval of one of these drugs and
restrict access to care to Millions a
frightening precedent imagine for a
moment if a judge was poised to strike
down access to another safe and
effective drug routinely used as part of
Medical Care like Tylenol or Advil
we would call it out for exactly what it
is
inappropriate overreach
they know the difference between Advil
or one of these other medicines is that
um
that medicines
are designed and they are prescribed
then administered to treat ailments
that's what a medicine does that's what
medicine is
that's what it's supposed to be
sort of doctor is supposed to do to to
treat
ailments
illnesses diseases injuries
that's what medicine exists for that
and really not for anything else
that's all it's supposed to do
that's a lot though
illness ailment disease injury
medicine the the you know the medical
industry and Medicine itself the actual
medicines that are prescribed that all
exist to to treat those things treat
ailments
um
abortion is not medicine
because it doesn't do that
and there's no way around this even if
you still support abortion and you think
it's a good idea to kill babies
obviously horrifically wrong
about that but you should at least admit
that this is not medicine
just because it happens in a in a in a
hospital or in a clinic that looks a
little bit that has a medical look to it
and this is a very sanitized kind of
look and you wait in the waiting room
and maybe there's somebody in a in a
white coat that performs the quote
procedure that doesn't make it medicine
because there's no there's no ailment
there's no illness being treated
pregnancy is not an illness
a baby is not a disease
we might treat the baby like a like a
cancerous tumor but the baby is not a
cancerous tumor the baby is a baby
again there's no way around this it is
not medicine pregnancy is not an ailment
it is not something to treat and get rid
of like a disease
now we should treat we we provide
treatment to pregnant women
to facilitate their pregnancy and to
deal with problems that come up during
the pregnancy
but the pregnancy itself is not an
ailment
it might be um
inconvenient
but an inconvenience is not a sickness
this is another
you know this is a this is a a common
source of confusion in our culture today
it goes beyond actually the abortion
industry
or anything that's inconvenience
anything that interferes with our
lifestyle becomes automatically a
sickness
but that's not what a sickness actually
is
so uh Ayanna Presley that's that's why
it's not that's why it's not a medicine
and as far as she says yeah it's a it's
a human right abortion's a human right
of course
not surprised to hear say that this is
their position
but I've yet to hear them um
explain that what do you mean it's a
human right
how do you know it's a human right
and where
where do you where does this human right
come from where does it originate
where do rights come from in general
you know the founders of our country
believe that human rights are rooted in
in the Supernatural and God they come
from the Creator
right we are we um
we have our human our natural rights by
virtue the fact that we are human beings
and do we endowed with them by the
Creator
is that what you believe
so then are you then claiming that we
have a natural god-given right to kill
our children so God creates the baby but
then also gives us the moral right to
kill those babies that he creates
is that the argument you want to make
and if the right doesn't come from God
then where's what are you talking about
what do you mean where does it come from
how do you know it exists
the only other option is that the Right
comes from the government that's where
all rights come from and it's just
something that the government comes up
with well basically arbitrarily it's uh
the rights are rooted in the whims of
the government but the problem then is
that if the government says okay we're
taking that right away then it doesn't
make any you have nothing to appeal to
beyond the governor you have nothing
Beyond or above the government to appeal
to this doesn't make any sense to say
well no that's a right you can't take it
away
well the government decides what a right
is so if the government says it's not a
right anymore then it's not
what you should then be arguing all you
can argue is that this should be a right
here's why I think this should be a
right
but you can't say that it is because
according to you a right is determined
entirely by whatever the government says
now they never have this speaking of
difficult conversations here's one that
they don't have
on the left they are constantly talking
about rights human rights they never
explain where they're getting any of
this from or what they think or who they
think the right is rooted in
what or or who is the source of that
right
this is not some
um
complicated well it might be someone
complicated but it's not a it is it is
not a purely philosophical exercise it's
not a purely academic question about
where our rights come from it it is uh
it's it's a it is a fundamental
critical question that needs to be
answered
no surprise me of course they can't of
course they can't Define a term like
human rights
um which is abstract
of course they can't Define that or they
can't even Define what you know what a
woman is
no big surprise there all right before
we get to the comment section one other
very important conversation to have here
um New York Post a newly resurfaced
video of a doordash driver who refused
to give a man his food after he only
tipped her eight dollars for a delivery
and 2021 has gone viral
the video which has been viewed nearly
one million times on YouTube shows ring
camera footage of the woman yelling at
the man for the seemingly measly tip
when she won when she went on a 12 and a
half mile trip for the food
I think we have that doordash uh ring
camera footage let's watch
now you believe it thank you
I believe it
I know I could speak too actually
I'm sorry
I need to speak to you I don't think you
realize where they're coming from so I
need to speak to you
where what's coming from
where the food you ordered is coming
from I don't think you realize
the distance that it's come from because
then you would never actually have given
what you would give so I think
you can come and see face to face
because I drew 40 minutes I drove 40
minutes and it was extremely far and I
got it to do early
so I don't think you realize where you
went from
Stan all right
Sasha's complaining and then actually
she takes food and drives away she
doesn't give them the food because he
only gave it it only gave an eight
dollar tip that's what blows my mind
about this I mean people are are bold
these people are bold and certain like
in the worst kinds of ways you know
there are times when it's when when uh
it's good to be bold and even good to be
confrontational and and stand up and
speak out and
but these days people aren't very bold
in those sorts of situations it's like
someone's being assaulted on the subway
uh you know or that and that's when we
get into the uh bystander effect and
everyone sits around maybe the recorder
they don't do anything but but if you if
you don't get a tip that for yourself
that you think is big is is good enough
now their people are willing to speak
out about that I can't even
I can't even imagine this I mean I did I
I delivered pizzas for a while when I
was younger and I got bad tips plenty of
times the idea that I would knock on the
door and say excuse me uh this tip's not
good enough I need more I need to give
me more money
never would have even occurred to me
only because I would have been
embarrassed to do that I would have felt
like uh like a a panhandler doing that
people are embarrassed about panhandling
these days that's the other problem I
mean you see you see people that uh that
I think we talked about this in a daily
cancellation once uh many moons ago but
this is the thing people they put their
their cash app or venmo or whatever on
their windshield of their car so just
asking anyone who happens to drive by
for money that kind of thing
so I guess it's no surprise to see this
but eight dollars an eight dollar tip
is really good especially for ubereats
or doordash
and this is a problem now now I know if
you're if you if you're an ubereats
driver doordash driver uh you know you
don't get it's not like all the money
that's spent is is going directly to you
obviously and so I don't know how much
they actually make from
you know from Uber I don't know how much
of the service fee goes to them versus
the tip but yeah they need the tip in
order to make this profitable for them
but at the same time it's a it's a real
problem
because because of the additional
service fees and everything
you're already if you if you order like
a forty dollar meal for two or something
on ubereats it's up to 65 before you
even had to tip in
so
it's a it's a problem it is bringing me
more and more steadily to the conclusion
that we just need to be done with
tipping completely it's gotten way out
of hand
everyone asks for a tip now but at the
same time so every tipping is expanding
it's becoming much more ubiquitous than
it's ever been before everyone's asking
for it but at the same time everything's
becoming more expensive alongside it
something's got to give I think we just
got to get rid of tipping be done with
it you know many other countries
cultures they don't do the Tipping thing
I think we just need to
we need to uh get with the times on this
one I don't see any other solution
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
you know the the least manly thing about
me there aren't many things but one of
them is that I do Experience car
sickness I don't know if that uh calls
my manhood in question or not but uh but
that's that's what I experience I have a
real bad problem with with motion
sickness look for many different
solutions for it and uh the one solution
I found that always works is relief band
relief band is the number one FDA
cleared anti-nausea wristband clinically
proven to quickly and effectively
prevent or relieve nausea and vomiting
Associated motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy whether you need everyday
nausea release or an occasional cure
you've got to check out relief band as
the name says relief band is just
legitimately a band you're wearing your
risk your risk to give you relief from
nausea to even change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling relief
band has an A plus rating With Better
Business Bureau over 100
000 satisfied customers as well if you
want the band that actually works to
relieve your nausea check out relief
then I've worked out an exclusive offer
Jeff just for my list listeners but you
got to go to reliefband.com use promo
code Walsh and you'll get 20 off plus
free shipping go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use promo code
walls for 20 off plus free shipping
orange banana says hey Matt my city
decided to paint a hideous rainbow at a
crosswalk and it costs nearly thirty
thousand dollars to do so meanwhile one
block away is an entire park and cluster
of houses completely infested with drug
and gang violence which a local PD
refuses to address all of our major
roadways are home to cauldron sized
potholes and inches wide fissures uh the
the city would rather spend Millions on
stupid useless symbols and public art
installations to Signal a
culture-mindedness while the citizens
and people who actually need help are
entirely neglected this stuff bothers
not for its direct symbolism but the
indirect symbolism that regular people
don't matter to the regime
um
well why not both
then you raise a good point but it's
both
it's the direct symbolism
which is which is the the the political
statement this is a political statement
that governments local government state
government the federal government is
endorsing and promoting a political
statement
um it really is it's not much different
than if if they if they um
you know if there was a flag
with the Democrat Party flag with like
the donkey Democrats are the donkeys
right the elephants yeah
um
it it would be like that it it it's it's
like a state local federal government
flying a Democrat Party flag right next
to the American flag it's a political
statement that's what the um pride flag
is
and so the direct symbolism is a problem
but also as you point out the indirect
symbolism which is only barely indirect
that they only care
about this they care about signaling to
their preferred groups
they care about supporting or at least
pretending to support their preferred
groups but uh not anybody else
masked music man says
want to hear what's really sad Matt
Hunter was once a Christian conservative
YouTuber
yeah so the guy we canceled yesterday in
the daily cancellation responding to his
arguments about child castration
um I never heard of them before and then
I saw this in the comments apparently he
used to be a Christian conservative
YouTuber with a with a larger following
than he has now and then he um
and so that from what I from what I was
told he was like this this total
implosion and now he's this leftist
whack job I find that
especially on the gender stuff I find
that very interesting you know
um it's one thing to have someone who
who had unformed opinions to begin with
get sucked into the gender cult and uh
led into it and they're not really
thinking much about it and so that's one
thing but to have someone who knew
better
like you you understood
that gender ideology is ridiculous you
understood all of this
and then you were what convinced what
what did anyone say to convince you so
at one point you understood that men
have penises women have vaginas
um that men can't have babies and but
now you think otherwise
what what argument was presented to you
that made you go oh you know what I
think I think I'm totally wrong about
this this thing that I knew for sure and
that the entire world knows for sure and
has always known yeah I think I'm wrong
I think you're right I think it turns
out all that what could have possibly
been what what argument could have
possibly been made that would cause that
uh
conversion to happen I'd really love to
know
it's fun to see you all be Pro vandalism
all of a sudden I remember a time when
Matt would have preferred to see vandals
have their hands cut off or something
well the vandals in the case of the uh
of the pride murals on the road they
didn't use their hands first of all they
used tires
so it would that wouldn't be appropriate
anyway and um and also look not all
vandalism is is made equal
uh that's that's just the reality not
all vandalism I thought I'm encouraging
vandalism I'm encouraging it okay
I couldn't do that
I couldn't do that on the show so I'm
not encouraging it but
um it's it's not it's not all made equal
I'm sorry it's just not
someone driving over a political
statement a political symbol that's been
put on the roadway by the local
government but in the roadway someone's
driving over it and leaving tire marks
even if they left the tire marks on
purpose that is not the same as say a
vandal who uh is part of the BLM mob and
burns down a store or even just like
your petty vandals who are destroying
their Community local businesses and
buildings and places places where people
live you know and and making it ugly and
dirty and disgusting you know there's
that kind of vandalism which I think
should be treated much more harshly than
it is
and then there's this where you have
citizens
who are rightly upset
by political statements being made and
endorsed by their government
and the government that is that it's not
that the vandals making the city
uglier
it's the it's the mural that's doing
that
the other thing about vandalism is that
usually it's you're making your own
Community uglier and dirtier and more
disgusting
but the person who puts the pride flag
mural up
trans pride flag which is totally
hideous and puts that so it's it's 30
feet long in the middle of the road
they are actually the Vandals
it's not the person who drives over the
flag that's vandalizing it's the person
who puts the flag in the road that's
vandalizing
so that's how I would uh parse that so
finally
um
let's see it says Matt looting is a
Robin Hood situation it's the hoods
doing the robin
we are really coming on strong with the
vaguely racist dad jokes in the comment
section recently
and um
I'm okay with it I'm okay with it
you know we live in a culture of such
permissiveness that there is no such
thing as excessive anymore the seven
deadly sins are no longer sins right
anything goes well if you want the best
life for yourself it might not be the
best idea to get into every Last
Temptation that might sound
controversial in today's age of
indulgence but it's actually not in fact
it's the smartest thing you can do
Jordan Peterson touches on this in his
new five-part series called vision and
Destiny on daily wire plus here's a clip
check it out you have to learn to
regulate Temptation right alcohol use
drug use sexual misbehavior defined by
the engagement in sexual activities that
cause your life to deteriorate if you
need a definition of what constitutes
sexual pathology that's it
and so you might want to have you might
want to have a strategy say do you like
to drink it's like okay
well how much
you know do you really need to drink 40
beer in three days or two days maybe
that's a bit much especially if it's an
iterated
process because it's going to take you
downhill it's like well you want to have
a drink now and that well how much and
when
optimally not as a constraint set
against yourself but if you were going
to use it properly what would proper
look like and then maybe you'll be able
to regulate your behavior because you're
not
tyrannizing yourself into abstinence
you're saying well if I want to have a
well-balanced life that might include a
bit of the disinhibition that I get from
alcohol and the social sociability that
comes along with that and
you know the community that's part of
the local pub let's say it's like fair
enough man but
why don't you do that like a uh
conscious Visionary instead of a dimwit
drunk
the fourth episode of vision of Destiny
is out today new episodes are releasing
every week but it's all exclusive for
daily wire Plus members you can join out
dailywire.com subscribe to watch vision
and Destiny and I'd really recommend
that you do that now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation in the
interest of efficiency we'll be
responding rapid fire style to uh Tick
Tock videos attacking me just over the
past two weeks or so so we're gonna go
through a number of rebuttals here uh
the interest of time I had to choose
only four from the options my producer
sent to me and uh there were a lot more
though and I say this will be rapid fire
but take that with a grain of salt I'm
not Ben Shapiro so rapid fire is
relative anyway let's go through these
I wouldn't really call this an apology
and make no mistake Dylan Mulvaney is
our enemy he is an open visible active
and passionate Advocate or the abuse of
children the war on fundamental truth
the destruction of human society as we
know it no Dylan Mulvaney does not
advocate for child abuse and gender
affirm and Care isn't child abuse anyway
as it's been found that not providing
trans Healthcare to youth is actually
closer to a form of child abuse trans
kids who are rejected from their family
were nearly 60 more likely to commit
suicide 73 more likely to end up in
prison and 68 more likely to suffer from
substance abuse one study found that 73
of trans youth experience psychological
abuse and 39 physical abuse so we can
clearly prove that trans people are not
committing child abuse but for the other
two claims I don't know what to do about
that they're so over the top and
dramatic war on Truth the downfall of
society how can you prove or disprove
that this is where I think Matt Walsh's
resentment has a little bit more to do
with Envy I mean I resent Matt Walsh
because I think he's a fascist but I do
also envy him I envy his status his plan
for the fact that people might take him
more seriously then they'll take me but
what if anything does Matt Walsh Envy
about queer people does he Envy Dylan
because she grew to such popularity so
fast is he envious of the fact that she
got invited to things like fashion shows
different events that she's met the
president
now we've already dealt extensively with
the claim that gender transition
decreases suicides right suicide rates
uh and uh we talked about it for 15
minutes yesterday so you can go and and
refer to that video
to see uh me breakdown why that part of
what he said is totally nonsense to the
charge that I am envious uh because
Dylan Mulvaney gets to go to fashion
shows I don't know what to say except
that attending a fashion show would be
my actual hell I mean almost as bad as
going to a WNBA game and I'm already
going to be forced to do that so A man
can only take so much
as for meeting the president yes I admit
that I would be very eager for a chance
to sit across from the president with
the cameras rolling
um but for very different reasons so
overall no I'm not envious of Dylan
Mulvaney I mean in order to elicit Envy
he would need to have something that I
want or embody some sort of trait that I
find admirable instead he has none of
the things I want out of life and
embodies everything that I want to be
the opposite of
so what we've learned here as you even
admitted to your credit I suppose is
that you are driven by Envy and so you
assume that everyone else is two and
this is what we call projection
now the next video is from the same guys
so uh let's continue
Matt Walsh is a fascist who is promoting
violence against trans people his
language is inflammatory and factually
incorrect the idea that being trans is
the result of some kind of social
contagion has been disproven so many
times the theory of Rapid onset gender
dysphoria comes from a survey of 256
parents of trans children and not from
the trans children themselves the
article has been removed and criticized
for bad methodology after being
peer-reviewed it was found that rapid
onset genders for it isn't even a formal
medical diagnosis it was found that
between 2017 and 2019 the rates of
teenagers identifying as trans didn't
even increase
well where to begin you say that the
survey about rapid onset gender
dysphoria was invalid because they
interviewed parents rather than the
children themselves well
yes if a child is sucked into a social
contagion he's not going to report that
he's been sucked into a social contagion
are you actually trying to prove that
children aren't being indoctrinated by
arguing that the indoctrinated children
say they haven't been indoctrinated is
that what you're going with
yes I mean if you go to your local
Scientology Center and you ask anyone
there whether they've been brainwashed
they're all going to say no
I guess that proves that there's no
brainwashing happening there either they
didn't say they were brainwashed so I
guess they weren't
now if you do uh if you don't like the
term rapid onset gender dysphoria you
can call it whatever you want if you
prefer something less clinical sounding
then just call it uh wow look at all of
these kids calling themselves trans all
of a sudden syndrome
the point is that according to data
compiled by The Williams Institute for
example nearly one in five people who
identify as trans are between the ages
of 13 and 17.
only half a percent of all adults in
this country identify as trans while the
number for kids between the ages of 13
and 17 is 1.4 that's nearly three times
higher
and the numbers are even more striking
when you break them down by generation
there's a Gallup poll that found that
there are twice as many trans
identifiers in gen Z as there are among
Millennials
and there are many more among
Millennials than among Baby Boomers for
Baby Boomers it's uh 0.2 percent
identify as trans for Gen Z it's it's
nearly two percent point two percent
versus two percent that is a 10 X
increase
you think this happened by accident
or perhaps you would say that there have
always been this many trans people in
the world but they weren't free to live
their truth or whatever well the trouble
with that theory is that there's
absolutely not even one single shred of
evidence to support the dramatic claim
that there have always been Millions
upon millions of closeted trans people
through history
so here's how this break's done all of
the available data all of it
tells us that there are many many many
many many many
more trans identifying people in the
youngest generation than in any other
generation in human history now you can
either believe what the data tells you
what all of it tells you all of it
or you can invent a story entirely
unsupported completely built on your
imagination about millions and millions
and millions of theoretical trans people
in older Generations who don't show up
in the data
this is what you're reduced to because
you don't want to accept what your eyes
tell you and tell all of us that trans
identification has skyrocketed in recent
years you're left then theorizing about
invisible trans people and other
Generations even though you have no
evidence that they even exist
all right let's move on
I had an unfortunate experience today
when I logged onto Facebook and I saw
this post by Matt Walsh I'll be honest
with you I thought it was satire I
thought Matt Walsh was either making a
joke or that he had been hacked but upon
further investigation
this was serious so let's read it
together
all a man wants is to come home from a
long day at work to a grateful wife and
children who are glad to see him and
dinner cooking on the stove this is
literally all it takes to make a man
happy we are simple give us this and you
will have given us nearly everything we
need the only truth in this entire post
is where he says we are simple you're
right you guys are simple-minded little
it gets better when he moves to the
comment section because people obviously
give him bunch of
if your husband is unhappy consider
whether you have ever given him this one
thing he wants there's a good chance the
answer is no
oh the outrage obviously every situation
is different maybe there's a situation
where both spouses have to work
especially in this economy maybe the man
Works seven shifts basically yeah I know
I'm a idiot I don't know if if
I've told y'all this story about when I
was being abused in my marriage and I
I'm not to like toot my own horn I was a
pretty good wife like I was the wife who
stayed fairly fit after two C-sections I
kept the house clean I did the laundry I
made the dinner the kids were happy and
well behaved and disciplined and I tried
my hardest because this is how I was
raised okay this is I was raised by a
stay-at-home mom I was raised with kind
of the mindset of like this is your job
is to like make him know that like he's
appreciated and that his house is taken
care of and yeah on top of all that I
did all the fun little things in the
bedroom he wanted me to do I would send
him dirty pictures at work and try to
keep the spice alive I would buy new
lingerie everything that you can think
of I was like I'm gonna be a good wife
like I am going to make this work and I
got more and more desperate to try to be
a better wife the worse it got because I
was taught like this Matt Walsh post
that if it failed if the marriage failed
if we weren't happy if he wasn't happy
it was on me it was because I wasn't
grateful enough it was because dinner
wasn't ready soon enough it was because
I wasn't fun enough I wasn't spicy
enough and he still abused me he still
cheated
well I'm sorry you had that experience
in your marriage I am never should have
happened
but you're making a mistake that many
people make these days of assuming that
a general principle is wrong because of
your own personal experience so it's
like if I said that you should lock your
doors at night and use an alarm system
to prevent break-ins and you responded
that my advice is bad because you did
that and still had to break it
okay but does that mean that you
shouldn't lock your doors and use an
alarm system if a certain strategy isn't
totally foolproof uh and perfect does
that automatically make it bad
what I'm recommending is that women
should be grateful and loving towards
their husbands that's it that's all I'm
saying now it's true that you could be
grateful and loving to your husband and
still end up in a terrible marriage
because he's a terrible person that can
happen terrible people exist in the
world and there are people who end up
married to terrible people it does
happen and it happens on both ends
because they're terrible women and
terrible men
but does that mean that wives shouldn't
be grateful and loving I mean are you
recommending in gratitude and resentment
is that a better strategy is that more
likely to produce positive marital
results
you can be faithful to your spouse and
still find that he is Unfaithful but
does that mean that we should tell
people to be unfaithful from the start
on the assumption that the others will
be too
of course not
but maybe your point is that
we shouldn't put it all in the wife we
should tell the men to be grateful and
loving too well here's the good news I
never suggest otherwise in fact I
frequently encourage men to love their
wives and be faithful and good to them I
say that all the time I just didn't
happen to make that point in that
particular statement that you read there
are many points that I didn't make
because I was only making the point that
I did make I can't say everything every
time I say anything and that limitation
does not give you the right to invent a
whole series of opinions and statements
I never expressed
which is what you just did
all right uh last one let's watch it
you cannot be something and also the
negation of that thing at the same time
Matt Walsh is just going to be upset
with people using micro labels see he he
wants to have it both ways where he
hates the oversaturation of language
with micro labels yet when something is
not 100 consistent and precise enough he
gets mad at that too you can't have it
both ways either we have to use umbrella
terms which are not going to be exactly
precise yet as long as we understand
that if somebody says bisexual and
asexual they're probably referring to
romantic attraction to both genders or
perhaps a little sexual attraction to
both genders if this is that Matt Walsh
is taking it is going to be logically
inconsistent for him to later take issue
with micro labeling five minutes later
start sniffing mumbo jumbo and now he's
taking issue with micro labeling despite
earlier
complaining that macro labeling is not
specific enough
well thank you for reminding me about my
fart sniffing mumbo jumbo line I'm quite
proud of that now my issue uh is not
with the act of labeling there is some
amount of labeling that's necessary and
normal human beings label things so that
they can communicate coherently with
each other about those things but
coherence is the point here when the
labels create incoherence then they
defeat the purpose of the entire
exercise if the label doesn't clarify
but rather creates more confusion then
it's not even a label it's more of an
anti-label it's an attempt to make it
harder for people to understand what
something is not easier
my issue with the labeling that you
people do is that you label obsessively
and constantly but your labels don't
make sense and they don't cohere they
contradict themselves and you can't
Define any of them that's the problem
case in point you mentioned someone who
identifies as both bisexual and asexual
that doesn't make sense I'm not being
pedantic I'm not engaging in a game of
gotcha here it just doesn't make sense
it is a logical contradiction it is the
definition of something that doesn't
make sense calling yourself a bisexual
asexual
is exactly like calling yourself a meat
eating vegan now you say that perhaps
asexuals experience a little sexual
attraction to both sexes and that
somehow justifies calling uh you know an
asexual that sort a bisexual asexual but
that's like saying that a meat eating
vegan is a vegan who eats only a little
bit of meat
well by definition if you eat a little
bit of meat then you eat meat which
means you aren't a vegan you may be a
less enthusiastic meat eater or a
reluctant meat eater or an occasional
meat eater or maybe there's some other
adjective you can affix there but a
vegan is someone who doesn't eat meat
period
you eat meat you aren't a vegan an
asexual experiences no sexual attraction
If you experience sexual attraction
you're not asexual see this is the other
problem with your compulsive and
incoherent labeling you don't allow for
variations within the labels you pretend
that you do you pretend that you're all
about very you're all about variation
you embrace all kinds of variety you
claim but you don't because the moment
you notice a variation within a category
you create a whole new category for that
variation
so rather than just allowing for the
fact that sexual people heterosexual
homosexual people who experience sexual
attraction
rather than allowing for the fact that
there are varying sexual appetites and
there are uh you know people that are
that that have greater appetites than
others rather than just allowing for
that you carve out anyone with a lower
appetite and you put them in the asexual
box you've removed them from this box
and put them in this one instead
and you do this kind of thing everywhere
in every context the most obvious
example of course is how you've
eliminated masculine women from
existence tomboys we used to call them
you've erased that variation by labeling
them trans men
see this is the worst part about the way
that you label it's not just that it's
incoherent
it's bad enough
it's also that it's so damned limiting
and furthermore
you're canceled all these people in fact
are today unfortunately I must say
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of shows and move over to the members
block you become become a member today
by using Code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]